Gregory two in a row one of them against
the defending champion this Victory must
feel quite sweet especially with the
black pieces
yeah yeah feels feels great didn't
expect it uh to happen and especially so
quickly so it's especially because it
felt like out of the opening sharp you
equalized but it didn't feel like you're
going to get much more than that and yet
the game at some point ended in a couple
of moves we missed it we were like okay
what happened here it was like exactly
you see you are aided by computers so
your feeling is different so I don't see
a computer evaluation so I felt like I
had initiative but of course I didn't
know whether it's more uh than for
equality but it was I I was hoping so
and you could notice uh right before I
played the final combination I started
repeating moves so I was very seriously
considering just shaking a strawberry
petition but then I saw this idea which
I which happened in the game and which I
did not expect to happen I saw this
variation but I was sure you know he's
not going to move the knight from D2 he
had other moves
um and uh I thought it's going to be and
just before we get to that point I think
this was a crucial moment when he took
on D4 and you decided to break with D5
how did you come to this conclusion what
was your assessment tell us a bit about
this position
uh obviously I felt like my development
Advantage is very important I have three
minor pieces developed versus his only
one uh so as the concept goes when you
have development Advantage open position
up so I try to do go for a pawn break to
trade pawns an open position up uh I
also emphasize while teaching activity
is much more important than Pawn
weaknesses I didn't care about the pawn
on E6 so I just tried to open and
activate my pieces as much as possible
even at this point I did too you
emphasized keeping the grip on his right
development the
is actually Galactic movie it's
obviously not easy move to play because
Bishop is very active on C5 but he's
about to complete his development with
Knight E4 and I absolutely have to stop
this move yeah yeah even at the expense
of a pawn very nicely assessed I have to
say Rook to E4 King to h8 another good
prophylactic move right Queen to B3
Knight to D3 and this was the moment
probably Rook 2 G4 was the only way for
him to maintain some sort of a balance
in the position not an easy move to make
very difficult I I didn't see this move
and I'm sure where are you going with
her right right right right typical
computer move looks like just a bad move
but I guess now after you told me I see
certain logic behind this move because
the main idea is that E4 is a crucial
Square for the Knight because it
protects of two it's going to jump on G5
but wherever it goes on the file it's
going to be attacked by my pieces so I
guess that that's the point of Rook G4
about such a strange move yeah it is a
very difficult makes the most sense just
because you're defending right upon on
F2 and now you uh repeat it once this is
the repetition you were talking about
and you decide to go Rook C8 immediately
the blunder okay right right right so so
almost all night moves uh
E4 this is the most natural I guess but
now you have some taken Knight D4 is
that it
um
yes yes taken 94. right right uh maybe
even I was thinking about Knight D4
right away uh but uh maybe it doesn't
matter
yeah yeah 94 also works right it's just
easier to calculate right right but the
move I was calculating the move I was
expecting was Queen D1 again not easy
move to make very passive looking move
but I was expecting this move when I was
calculating variation Knight D4 Knight
shakes D4 Knight shakes F2 Rook chicks
F2 Queen shakes D4 and now either
Queenie one Queen F1 uh Rook C2 here so
I I wasn't sure what's going on but but
since he's good
I was hoping yeah that that something
will good will happen there yeah Knight
F3 actually you can continue sacrificing
and then pin
I was hoping for yeah no uh great game
it finished in an anticlimactic way but
still great result for you great start
of the tournament Gregory
congratulations thank you yes sir any
questions
relations to Gregory yeah very nice
start
and